[Inaudible].
Crack Helen here today.
We're going to talk about a film that explores the beautiful dynamics of a happy
loving family with zero trauma to speak of. Just kidding.
We're talking about hereditary,
a movie that makes Thanksgiving at the blues house.
Look like a Norman Rockwell painting.
Hereditary immediately established director.
Ari asked her as a bonafide bore Maestro,
but it's worth asking what makes a movie about your typical family?
One of the most disturbing horror films in recent memory,
the answer has nothing to do with naked Colts, demons,
or dark arts and everything to do with your DNA. Don't worry.
We'll explain in this wisecrack edition on hereditary and of course,
spoilers ahead. But first, since we can't count on payment for our riches,
we need you, at least, until we find a suitable host for two bucks a month,
you can get ad free access to all of wisecracks videos before anyone else that's
like too spicy potato soft tacos. What she won't be able to eat anymore anyway,
for a little more and still substantially less than your whole family dying.
You can also hang out with the wise crack team and other patrons on our
exclusive patron discord like here,
or go to patrion.com/wisecrack to check it out.
And now back to the show, hereditary centers around artists, Andy Graham,
who is sort of in mourning over the death of her estranged mother,
before she can even process that loss though, her daughter,
Charlie is killed in a free car accident while her son is at the wheel.
As Andy's whole world subsequently crumbles a mysterious woman,
teaches her to perform a seance, the channel's Charlie spirit,
and that's where everything goes a little, uh, off the rails.
Eventually we learned that Annie's dead.
Mom was part of a totally bananas pagan cult that is looking for a vessel for
its favorite demon by the end.
Pretty much everyone is the headedly worshiping Charlie spirit,
which has been planted into Peter's body. So why is it so scary?
Well, partially because it contains stuff like this.
But.
Horror films that really shake us,
tend to anchor even their most supernatural scares in our real life fears.
In hereditary case, the clue is in the name,
it's the story of a family doomed to misery by their lineage.
While most of us probably don't have to worry about our grandmothers being
secret. Occultists the idea that we might suffer for our parents' sins is pretty
universal and that universality has everything to do with hereditary scare
factor.
See some of the most unhinged events of the film can be explained by the concept
of refreshing. One of the cornerstones of Sigmund Freud, psychoanalytic theory.
Repression is the process by which the conscious mind is shielded from feelings
and thoughts,
which are too painful to acknowledge these buried emotions are left to fester,
unresolved,
and often manifest themselves in occasionally alarming ways like a,
this Indeed.
Annie is a case study in repression per life has been littered with tragedies
that she's unable to fully confront in her eulogy for her mother.
Any tries to find nice words to say,
but inadvertently ends up stressing how emotionally unavailable and controlling.
Was. My mother was a very secretive and private woman.
She had private rituals, private friends, private anxieties.
And he's true feelings bubble beneath the surface to repress,
to be articulated and too powerful to be let go.
This is pretty blatant for shadowing any,
he doesn't know how sinister her mother's private rituals were or that the
strange faces she sees in the pews are actually members of Ellen's Colt, right?
From the beginning,
the things that the Graham family hides are sowing the seeds of their own
destruction.
Amy's repression makes honest communication with those closest to her difficult.
If not impossible.
It's gets too cold. Come back in.
The only place she'll talk about her traumatic past is that a grief support
group full of strangers, even then she's completely detached,
reeling off the laundry list of horrifying things that occurred during her
childhood in an almost casual way.
She didn't have an easy life she had did,
which became extreme at the end and dementia.
My older brother had schizophrenia and when he was 16,
he hanged himself in my mother's bedroom. And of course the suicide note point,
her accusing her of putting people inside him. So.
That was my mom's.
It's notable that any finishes this speech by distancing herself from the
narrative, these are her mother's traumas, not hers,
even when acknowledging her family's history.
She's unwilling to accept it as part of her story.
And he's not unique in her inability to deal with tragedy during what Freud
calls, the first use of the psychoanalytic approach,
the patient and an O was encouraged to make political compositions that could
offer her relief from her chronic anxiety,
using art to express what she couldn't say out loud fittingly and he's art
functions in the same way.
She makes miniature doll houses that recreate her traumatic life events.
However,
it's not accurate to call Andy's creepy model home therapeutic Freud emphasize
that it's not enough to artistically depict traumatic events.
The patient also has to engage with the emotions attached even as any
recreates, her past traumas and my new detail.
She refuses to acknowledge the emotional payload.
They carry something which becomes ghoulishly clear after she creates a bleak
depiction of Charlie's death and Peter's role in it. It's.
Not about him. No, no. It's.
A neutral view of the accident,
but any strange behavior is ultimately understandable.
She's coping with her trauma all on her own. When tragedy strikes,
we hope to lean on the people around us for support often relying on a stable
familial structure to hold us together.
However many modern familial units are really not set up to deal with such
emotions. In fact, many aren't really set up to deal with emotions at all.
Don't you swear at me don't you ever raise your voice at me.
I am your mother.
And that brings us to what really makes hereditary so scary family
in these surprisingly whimsical bestseller families and how to survive them.
Dr. Robin Skinner and British comedian, John Cleese elucidate.
Why talking openly with our loved ones can feel so impossible and its lessons
become all too relevant in hereditary,
which is all about people who are fundamentally unable to survive their own
family.
Or like ponds this horrible hopeless machine.
The book centers on the premise that most of our attitudes and characteristics
are grounded in our original family experience and relationships and argues that
repressed people tend to form family units that are also repressive.
I E the Graham's Annie and her husband, Steve lie to one another,
rather than dealing with upsetting emotions.
She hides the fact that she is going to a grief support group,
and he hides the fact that her mother's grave has been desecrated.
His chronic inability to communicate soon comes back to haunt them.
Where was it?
Just some billing crap. Okay, well, I'm, uh, I'm going to go see a movie.
The perpetual secrecy that hangs over their relationship leads to mistrust and
even paranoia as when Steve accuses any herself of being responsible for
desecrating the grave.
The grade was you wasn't it all those nights.
You were pretended to go to the movies.
Here. The staggeringly toxic results of family wide repression become abundantly
clear.
And the same is true for the Graham's children after the grandmother's funeral,
Annie and Steve,
try to prompt Charlie and Peter to open up about their feelings to no avail,
not surprising given their parents reluctance to honestly voice their own
emotions.
Charlie is repressed to the point where she barely talks responding to emotional
stimuli with a strange and truly terrifying clicking noise. Instead,
she is particularly unable to express anything negative or confrontational when
forced into an argument, she simply concedes that's okay.
And we learned that her practice of suppressing emotions started very early,
never cried as a baby. Peter,
on the other hand, buries his emotions under a cloud of marijuana smoke,
normally sleep walking through much of the day.
His parents do the same popping prescription pills to blank out their own
feelings.
So what happens when you make four deeply repressed people share a home,
you know, stuff like this
Grams are completely cut off from one another emotionally compartmentalize into
separate rooms. As if in one of Andy's miniatures,
even in the wake of Ellen's death,
the family is more concerned with how they are supposed to feel than how they
actually feel.
Should I say you should be whatever you are.
It'll come.
As a result. The are totally unequipped to deal with Charlie's death,
which has made gallingly clear by Peter's decision to cocoon himself in bed,
leaving his parents to discover her body.
He is so unable to process the trauma and his role in it that he simply shuts
down in an emotionally healthy family. The trauma of Charlie's death, though,
intolerably painful could be the impetus for self-reflection and even
growth in life and how to survive it. Another book written by the doctor,
comedian duo Skinner explains that the healthier people are the more they are
willing to admit to their limitations.
And so the more open they are to the possibility of improvement,
but the grams were emotionally unhealthy. Even before the tragedy in its wake,
that they are unable to reckon with the pain or even ask for help.
In the rare moments, when the Graham's do talk about their feelings,
it gets ugly fast in one exchange, any projects,
many of her own problems onto Peter or refusing to recognize them in herself.
Even at this explosive moment, she continues to repress her feelings,
specifically her guilt about Charlie's death.
I can't accept. And I can't forgive because
what about you, mom? She didn't want to go to the party.
Why was she there?
But any his inability to get in touch with her feelings,
isn't some kind of moral failing. It was somewhat inevitable.
Skinner talks about how many of our painful experiences are ultimately a
simple consequence of family history over which no one had any
control for the grams. This is certainly true.
Their grandmother ultimately dooms them,
but not just because of her pagan machinations,
rather her most potent legacy is her emotional detachment,
which continues to drive her family apart. Even after she's gone. In this sense,
the grams are beset by a very real family curse.
They each inherit the repressive tendencies of their parents,
which causes their trauma to fester until it's out of control,
as any explains in her eulogy, her mother was an emotionally distant person,
unable to offer her the love or support that she needed.
Fittingly Cleese argues that many of our problems are really childhood
difficulties that we fail to resolve when we were young and consequently carry
around with us in our adult lives.
It's no surprise then that Annie inherited a complex damaged idea of what it was
to be a mother, which in turn instilled a deep fear of becoming one.
She represses that fear though, burying it in her unconscious.
So it can only manifest in her dreams. I didn't feel like a mother,
both her dreamed confession and her murderous sleepwalking are byproducts of
these unwanted unthinkable ideas.
Any remains unable to accept them as of herself,
even after she almost burns her children alive.
She refuses to admit the severity of the situation.
Standing there with a box of matches and an empty canopy dinner.
And I woke myself up striking the match,
which also what Peter up and he started screaming.
To do.
So would mean acknowledging the part of her that wanted to harm her children,
shattering her already tenuous maternal identity. I mean.
I was just as shocked as he was,
and it was impossible to convince them that it was just sleep walking.
Unable to process her childhood traumas. She replicates them.
She unwittingly neglects, her children,
even giving Charlie to Ellen in a desperate attempt to win the approval.
She still craves.
Let her anywhere near me. When I had my first, my son,
which is why I gave her my daughter, who she immediately stabbed her hooks into.
And in turn, she creates kids who are just like her repressing,
their traumatic childhood experiences to preserve an image of normalcy,
Peter and Charlie can't confront the idea that their mother tried to kill them
or in Charlie's case, functionally gave her away any more than Annie can.
So the whole family continues stumbling forward and willful ignorance.
And this is where the freaky supernatural elements of the film becomes so
important.
The family's increasingly creepy experiences are symbolic of their dysfunction.
As a result,
they are blinded to all the signs that something sinister is brewing.
Even as they, each individually notice markings and apparitions,
they are unable to communicate about them for fear that their sanity will be
called into question. In fact,
Ellen's pagan tendencies only go unnoticed in the first place because of how
distant she and Annie are when she dies.
All her secrets are there to be discovered in a box in the attic,
but no one finds them until it is too late.
Fittingly the front emotional associations Annie has with her mother ensure she
won't do the work of sorting her belongings or her own emotions.
This lays the groundwork for Ellen's creepy friend,
Joan to enact the later stages of their plan. Sure.
They have hundreds of years of demonic knowledge and mystical energy on their
side, but their plan would be a non-starter.
If Annie had taken a brief flick through her, mom's old things,
the family's maladjustment makes them vulnerable in the first place after
drawing any in Joan offers her a basic psychological defense
denial. If any can believe in the seance,
then she doesn't have to really face the fact that Charlie is dead.
Doesn't have to reckon with her involvement in her death or reconciled that with
her fear of motherhood. So long as Charlie isn't dead,
that can all remain buried. You didn't kill him.
She isn't.
But the sands also serves a larger psychological purpose.
Dr. Skinner talks about how feeling plugged into a meaningful cosmic system
gives people a greater psychological balance and stability.
And that's exactly what Jones mysticism offers. Annie, her home life,
her whole world has been shattered and Joan offers her a way to piece it back
together to reconstruct her family.
Of course it is not inherently supernatural to believe that some part of the
people we lose lives on in us,
but sometimes it's not exactly the parts we would like several studies about
transgenerational trauma have suggested that the descendants of those who
undergo great suffering might carry the psychological markers of it themselves,
potentially leaving them more vulnerable to PTSD, anxiety, depression,
and other conditions.
One of the first studies into this phenomenon was undertaken by Canadian
psychiatrist, Vivian M Rakoff,
who found that the children of Holocaust survivors showed uncommonly high rates
of psychological distress Ralph's findings in subsequent studies give evidence
to the idea that trauma is passed down,
not only through the influence of our parents' behavior,
but through their genetic material in this way,
Ellen passes her own trauma on to Annie and Annie passes it on to Peter and
Charlie.
Each member of the family has developed their own repressive mechanisms to
ensure that their demons are never exercised.
Eventually those demons will destroy them.
The supernatural forces at play naturally paralleled the severe mental illness,
which runs in the family,
demonic possession and curses after all have historically been used as
explanations for mental health problems that could not be otherwise understood.
Ellen's husband and son both killed themselves as a result of schizophrenia or
psychotic depression.
Although her sons claimed that she was putting voices inside him,
raises the question of whether she was experimenting with demon raising,
even back then through these acts of violence,
the family self-destructive legacy is passed onto each member,
dooming them to the same bloody fate as those who came before much of who we are
is hereditary.
It's why so many of us can probably relate to Annie and her family feeling
somewhat doomed to repeat the past. And one day turn into our parents.
Ultimately the thing which locks the Graham family into their fate,
isn't ancient rites or mysterious ruins,
but their own inability to process the trauma they have undergone they suppress
and suppress and suppress it until it finally explodes.
The violence which comes exploding out is filled with darkly, poetic,
repetitions, and reversals,
any beheads herself in a gory imitation of Charlie's death.
Her nighttime fantasies of burning a family member alive come true.
When Steve goes up in flames.
[Inaudible].
Oppression and trauma lock them into a cycle and they're tortured.
Family history seems doomed to repeat itself until they have all been destroyed.
But what do you guys think?
Are we all doomed to repeat our family's dysfunction?
Let us know in the comments big, thanks to our patrons for your support,
light that subscribe button on fire, and as always,
thanks for watching peace.
[Inaudible].